[MUSIC PLAYING]
When we think about
trash, we often
don't imagine the
garments that we wear.
But when we're done
with them, they also
end up in landfills,
just like the trash
that we throw out every day.
The fashion industry is the
second top waste-producing
industry in the world.
Our trend cycle moves
extremely quickly,
which encourages consumers
to purchase and dispose
at a rapid rate, but that
leads to a lot of damage
to our environment from the
waste produced by our garments.
The MIT Trashion Show is
an annual fashion show
put on by MIT's Undergraduate
Association's Committee
on Sustainability.
And every year, we
invite designers
from all over the
Boston community
to design garments out of
unconventional or up-cycled
materials, and then have them
shown at our fashion show.
The show started 11
years ago, and we've
come a long way since then.
But the Trashion
Show's main goal
remains the same as it
did when it started,
which is to promote
awareness about the waste
that the fashion
industry produces,
and spark conversation about
where our clothes come from,
how they were made,
and where they
go once we're done with them.
Designers are encouraged to use
trash, or recycled materials,
or materials that
would otherwise
be thrown away, in order to
create pieces that can be worn.
So past materials have included
newspapers, soda boxes,
soda cans, electrical
wires, and things like that.
Clothing is usually very flowy.
It's very organic,
and needs to mold
to the shape of a human body.
So working around those material
properties can be difficult.
Typically, the designer
that wants to participate
is someone that wants
to tackle a challenge.
They come from all majors
and all backgrounds,
but ultimately, they're
looking for a creative outlet.
It's not very easy to create
a garment out of trash,
and it takes a lot of time.
So these people are
driven by risk taking.
And they want to make a product
that otherwise wouldn't exist.
The Trashion Show actually
takes a lot of work to organize.
You need to have AV.
You need to talk to
Facilities, book a venue,
and then also keep track of all
the models and designers who
are participating in the show.
Often, people are
just really amazed
to see a product that
they had just thrown away
worn on someone's body, and worn
in a way that is a functional
garment.
That's something that
people don't usually
get to see around campus.
When it comes to
judging, we have
a panel of three judges, all
related to sustainability,
but also coming from
different disciplines.
We provide them
a set of criteria
that involves whether an
outfit is sustainable,
how much recycled
material it uses,
how aesthetically it works,
and the technical fabrication
skills of the piece.
So we give out a few
different awards at the show--
first, second, and third,
and audience choice, but also
other committees on the
Undergraduate Association
Committee for Sustainability
give out prizes based off
of what they do.
So there's a lot of
different opportunities
to celebrate the different
aspects of pieces
that designers create.
When people think of MIT, they
usually don't think of fashion.
But in fact, a lot
of students here
are very interested in
fashion or just creating art.
And something really
special about MIT
is that kids have a
wide array of interests.
And maybe if fashion
isn't one of them,
the Trashion Show encourages
them to try something new.
And MIT kids always love
trying something new
and pushing their boundaries.
And creating clothes out
of trash is a challenge.
And it takes engineering,
and design, and technology,
which are all things
that students here
are very interested in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]